you're very smart
i feel like when it comes to
your finances you have lots of streams
of income
you just announced the new gaming system
which is your second one correct
second one i'm the first rapper to
release a video game concert
at soulja boy game instagram twitter and
tick tock
i'm about to put up 24 billboards all
throughout the city all over the world
and what's dope about this uh console is
it's got a bunch of different types of
systems on it right fortnite
spotify apple music tick-tock
netflix wow it's serious it's not even
this is a
home entertainment system handheld
though oh handheld
okay helio processor this
series touchscreen how much you're going
for 200
that's not bad twitch is like what or
not twitch
the switch is like three 299 that's not
bad yeah
get a five percent discount right now
soldier boy use that code
are you preloading your music on this
thing
it varies you're doing a lot of things
with this what you got to do is
every system a lot of customization
every system sold
you from the ground up but this is what
uh yeah it's a beautiful thing i own the
whole company
is is is i'm
very i'm very proud of this because it's
like music music i'm gonna say music was
a stepping stone to get into this
you know what i'm saying and then like
once you get into this industry it's
hard like it's it's not easy
it took me like three years to really
like get it how i wanted
how i want it to be to get it at this
level that i'm at right now right you
know what i'm saying
but like yeah man it's different right
right it's a whole different space it's
different from music it's different from
movies it's different from
anything i've been involved in right
are you trying to get in other fields
like no politics governments oh you love
video games no yes
this is a passion from the earlier i
don't do business based off of just like
business like you gotta love opening the
restaurant oh my god
no truck business you gotta be
passionate i gotta be something i was
you know i wanna have a toy since i was
young
i wanted to have my own clothing line
since i was young i wanted to have
my own video game console since i was
young so now that i'm older and i got
the connections
and i use music as a stepping stone to
get into these different fields
i can accomplish everything it seems
like too just based on reading about the
system is that it's a big improvement
from the first one
very big improvement because i think a
lot of people got might have got your
other
what happened with the other system
because it feels like i think some of
the shipping was
slow and then some people got it and
they weren't happy with it do you feel
like it's
just a learning process we had to recall
the first system first system
it it it garnered so much attention that
it got on nintendo's radar
and nintendo threatened legal action
because you had it you had everybody's
[ __ ] on there right
well basically the games that were on
there were licensed and trademarked but
some of them wasn't but through the
company that i went through
they were supposed to be 100 percent
covered on they're supposed to handle
all that but there weren't they wasn't
so once my name was on it you know what
i'm saying it was you took all the heat
yeah yeah
but that's fine because we come back
bigger and better we go from
getting a cease and desist from nintendo
from them coming and now trying to buy
my company from me damn
you understand what i'm trying to say
that's crazy and it's like oh
yeah i'ma sell it of course so
nintendo's trying to buy your company
off of you they write billion out of
checks like this i didn't talk to
nintendo and google
and the two companies that i talked to
that's big
they trying to buy us out right now it
ain't even been a month too much like
this ain't even hitting the shelf we
just
hit amazon stores like three days ago
[ __ ] congratulations
i'm gonna sell it you got to yeah it's
just i got like it's
i just got to like i would own it i
would keep it but it's like once you got
nintendo coming at you
it's just like do your thing right